I was only uh 17 when I first applied to
do ROTC I didn't come from a military
family so it wasn't really something we
had expected uh but after that uh ended
up sticking with it now I'm
here my name is Brandon kis I'm an Army
lieutenant colonel I've been in the
service for 17 years now and I'm a
foreign area officer I'm here at Yale
it's my first year in the political
science PhD program Yale has a long
history of veterans service being part
of this community of Scholars at least
for me there's been something satisfying
and whether you served a full career or
just for a few years um you joined
something that was a lot bigger than
yourself and made a commitment and
there's something uh honorable and
special in that and it gives me great
pride to be a part of that along with
[Music]
you